um so i wanted to touch back on the fact
that he was talking about conversion
and um sanctification so i kind of wanted to
um ask you to break down what does conversion
look like in a christian life and what is the
difference between conversion and sanctification
okay all right conversion in the life of a
christian in the life of anybody a converted
person is someone who has been changed who
has been born again someone who has been
transformed if you read john chapter 3 verse 6
read that for me john 3 verse 6. it's a simple
verse you know it well that which is born of the
flesh is flesh that which is born of the spirit
is spirit when you convert it you go from flesh
to spirit now the conversion has to be genuine
many conversions are not genuine
uh you have always writings there with you
go to faith and works page 96 paragraph three
ellen white will explain why there's so many
fake conversions in the church i mean you you
turn out to be a nice person but you're not really
converted faith and works page 96 paragraph three
i'll tell you where to begin you have it
faith and works page 96 paragraph three
now it starts with the reason why there's
so many spurious conversion in these days
is that there is so low an appreciation
of the law of god did you do you see that
the reason you see it okay we have a sister over
here who has it before you my brother reforest
nice and loud okay comes the money
there are so many serious conversions in
these last in these days uh-huh there is a
low appreciation it is so low sorry there is so
low an appreciation of the law of god ah okay
now genuine conversion will place a
person in conformity with god's law
go to god's amazing grace page 59 read paragraph
two who has the fact that who finds it first read
nice and loud i just said genuine conversion
places a person in the person lines up with
god's law here's the law here's the person you can
here's the law and here's this genuine conversion
a lot of converted people this is the law and
this is them genuine conversion places you in
conformity the law goes this way you go that way
now god's amazing grace page 59 paragraph two
wait for us the message that we
have to bear is not one that we need
cringe to declare its advocates are not
to seek to cover it is a verse that says
when this mighty change has
taken place in the sinner
this mighty change no it's not god's amazing
space 59 paragraph two you don't see that there
all right here's what it says the heart
is brought into harmony in conversion
the heart is brought into harmony with god as
it is brought into accord with his great law
now the brother is asking what's conversion
what's sanctification a converted person is
someone whose desire now is to live in total
harmony with god's standard of righteousness
god's standard it's actually page 20. page
20 paragraph paragraph five okay reading this
mighty change has taken uh uh-huh yes read
that when this mighty change has taken place
read the sentence before it in the new
birth in the new birth or conversion
the heart is brought into harmony with god
as it is brought into accord with his law
okay dwell on that a moment remember his
question what is conversion in the new
birth that's conversion the heart is brought
into what harmony with as it comes into what
with god's word great law yes there is no
conversion without harmony or accord with
god's law when this mighty change
has taken place keep reading sister
he has passed from when this mighty change
has taken place in the sinner he has passed
from death into life from sin unto holiness from
transgression rebellion obedience and loyalty now
that's converted person okay now the question is
what is sanctification sanctification is growing
growing in that growing in that change growing in
fitness to god because as you learn more you want
to do everything you learn that is the process of
sanctification and so jesus says sanctify them how
through thy truth thy word is truth sanctification
really is obedience to all god's commandments and
so first thessalonians chapter 4 verse 3 says and
this is the will of god even your sanctification
that you should abstain from fornication meaning
avoiding sin that's the process of sanctification
putting sin away from you every little thing
because we discovered things about ourselves
that we didn't know god reveals to us a converted
person learns about himself i didn't realize this
was in me when it's revealed you put it away and
you can grow and you keep growing what doesn't
change is your fundamental desire to do what's
right in god's sight i'll do it even if i die
i'll do it but i didn't know i was hardheaded
i didn't know god revealed it i put it away and
i keep moving because my desire is to do what's
right what's right what's right so conversion is
to come into harmony with god's law sanctification
is to remain in that and grow in that
you